is just another engineering discipline
but it's also has some interesting
advantages one advantages we have
extremely complex beautifully debugged
systems because they've been the
debugged over billions of years over you
know many orders of magnitude of land
and air and sand liquid we inherit that
so that's one thing advantage the other
advantage is we can reduce some of that
we can do evolution in the lab but we
could do evolution kind of on steroids
where we we can accelerate evolution so
we have that plus we have all the
advantages from all the engines other
engineering disciplines like
computer-aided design so all these
things combine to make something that's
highly accelerated but we have a fourth
thing which is extremely important and
maybe not all of this is that week is
that we want to atomic we what we we
would like to be able to do atomically
precise engineering if it's free and and
basically biology basically does that it
it almost everything it does is capable
of being atomically precise almost every
molecule is made is the same as every
other molecule of that type and that and
it does it at scale so you can make
things the size of a giant redwood or
the size of an entire ecosystem and
basically for free that forest didn't
really cost us anything to to build so
atomically precise at scale billions of
years evolution and ability to evolve on
our own so instead of making a prototype
in any other field of engineering like a
prototype for a bridge or a cell phone
where you really put a lot of energy
into one prototype here you can make a
trillion prototypes and let evolutionary
processes pick the best one you just
have to be clever about setting up the
accelerated evolution so this is
Christine the amazing capability of
biology including materials and it's not
just biologically inspired materials
where you can make atomic the precise
versions of things that are normally
imprecise
it's you know like instead of making
mortar we can make a shell you know with
all its intricate patterns on it mortar
is just kind of like blob of stuff these
smooth out but we can also make biology
make things that you normally don't
think are biological
all right not not shells but but like
shells made out of inorganic materials
so we should be able literally
everything we can make metals
semiconductors all of that we know how
to make those with my halogen we know
how biology can make metals it can make
it can make refractive index gradient
will optical fibers it can it it can
make Thinking Machines detect some of
the best supercomputers an oral or or
biologically manufacturing site I think
that nothing is currently manufactured
without biology is safe from from
disruption and revolution